news now special edition
good afternoon and thanks for joining us
here at 4 30 i'm vanessa murphy this is
a special edition of eight news now
we're calling vax facts for kids now
that children as young as five can get
the kovid 19 vaccine we want to help
families sort through information right
now just the pfizer vaccine has received
fda approval for kids ages five and up
now joining us in the studio to answer
questions dr rutu thachin also known as
dr e board certified pediatrician and
joanne ruper chief administrative nurse
at the southern nevada health district
we also have a group of parents joining
us on zoom here because this is a mix of
vaccinated and unvaccinated individuals
here the hope is for this to be a
judgment free zone and to have a
productive discussion now let's start
with dr e can you tell me what you
believe are the benefits and risks of
the covid19 vaccine for children
yes absolutely so i think when we're
talking about the benefits and the risks
of the vaccine we just need to
understand that the landscape for
covid19 has changed significantly in
just a year and a half when we first
started having our lockdown in march
2020 that variant that original coveted
strain was not making children sick the
same way they were they were seeming to
be relatively untouched not getting
hospitalized not dying from it however
this past summer when the delta variant
started we started seeing children get
sick and pediatricians really started
listening and noticing we saw a
five-fold increase in hospitalizations
we've started having children dying from
covid we're seeing increases in
multi-system inflammatory syndrome which
can last for months for some of these
children in terms of side effects so
this vaccine now is effective against
the delta variant and the benefit is it
can prevent hospitalization it can
prevent death it can prevent the
multi-system inflammatory syndrome that
children are experiencing the risks are
the same as any vaccine redness soreness
in the arm fever chills your and that's
really your body saying hey i'm making
an immune response and this vaccine is
working the risk of something really
serious like anaphylaxis shock is the
same with the coveted vaccine as it is
with all the other vaccines that your
children are taking
thank you so much now let's go to brian
almero brian you are a dad
you told me you and your wife are
vaccinated but you're on the fence about
getting the vaccine for your child can
you tell me why
so i mean it really comes down to it is
the side effects yeah i mean my wife
have been vaccinated since you know
beginning of the year or middle of the
year and it's the main concern really is
i know she mentions the usual
soreness and and uh usual um
the way
the way adults have it is going to be
the same as on the children
it comes down to it is really what more
is it really is that really all the
the side effects or is it more to it i
mean
it's been has it been really tested
i mean that's really my concern so so
it's it's kind of like
or in defense if we're going to do it
right away or is it better to win
thank you so much and dr e are you
seeing this
parents like brian who are on the fence
and and what would you say to them yeah
definitely i mean it's very
understandable to to want to know as
much as possible before administering
this for your child and i think what i
would say is in terms of the testing
this vaccine has had over 400 million
doses in the country
and so it's one of the most studied
vaccines we've ever had out there so
that the studies are robust lots of
people have been getting it they're
tracking the safety of it and it's
showing to be more
effective in younger kids and they
actually have less side effects than
older kids and adults
and for
joanne rupert can you talk about are you
seeing this at the health district some
parents like brian being hesitant and
and what would you say to them
well certainly i can understand their uh
their
concerns about vaccinating their
children
this vaccine
you know has been
rolled out it started last
july and 2020 but the
the research for the mrna the messenger
rna has been going on since 1990 and now
that we're in this pandemic
the urgency really
really forced the
rapid development of the vaccine and we
were able to also receive the
researchers were able to receive funding
for it so
the government had put a lot of funding
into getting this vaccine
developed and then also tested
thank you so much now up next we'll hear
from more parents both for and against
the covid19 vaccine for children we'll
be right back